This episode is sponsored by state form.
[Inaudible].
From 20th century studios. Okay. That just looks wrong.
Comes a film that was set to be released in 2018,
until it got delayed to avoid Deadpool, to delayed again,
to avoid dark Phoenix delayed again after Disney acquired box delayed again,
thanks to the Rona.
And after all that buildup and anticipation looks like the fourth best superhero
movie of 1995.
The new mutans.
It's been a long, strange trip at the movies for X-Men bans from good
to great, to bad,
to worse.
Now roll the dice and enterovirus field theater to see what kind of
experience will bring the era to a close.
Then watch them crap out like the last toured in a dump before Kevin foggy can
flush the whole thing down the toilet,
The new mutans who you'll come to wish were some kind of suicide squad there.
Sam, the Kentucky boy with the personality of a Cola. Yeah.
I had to go and work in the mines. My dad hates his job,
hates working in the mines with his dad, watched the call for my dad, gave him.
To me, Roberto, the human pop color,
a dag Arya stark who can walk into her dire Wolf.
Danny moon star, a girl who lives by that one,
native American proverb fitness influencers posted on their Instagram.
Inside every person. There are two bears.
I asked him which one wins Hansard, the one you feed.
And Ilianna who hates being trapped in the facility.
But since you can teleport must be sticking around for the racism.
This isn't the hospital Pocahontas doesn't have to grow weeds or, you know,
[inaudible], he's standing around you on the Buffalo wing.
Experience, a superhero movie that redefines low budget,
where they barely even use their powers.
Use your powers replay scenes from Logan and save money by
not hiring a dialect coach.
Seeing phones, terrible nightmares, lions and tigers and bears.
You'll thrill.
When Danny arrives at Savior's empty off-brand mutant teaching hospital,
a place with exactly one employee.
So the only Latino student has to do the cleaning
Together.
This party of five will undergo the old mutation equals puberty metaphor.
What's happening to me plus the usual act and horniness that comes with making
teens live together.
All while the evil Dr.
Rayez undergoes her sinister treatment plan,
telling them all to chill a bunch of times.
This we relax. You relax, calm down, calm, down,
and control.
Okay. Is anything actually going to happen in this movie?
Like a Mister sinister review or an X-Men cameo? No,
maybe a demon smoke beer X Mokena.
Okay. The last one was a joke. You guys, what are you thinking?
Do you like horror? No. Good.
Neither does this movie who scary. No,
but every 20 minutes they'll remember it was popular ones.
So they might as well try some childhood trauma hallucinations where each Mutan
gets a PG 13 spooky flashback, but without the scary clown to make it all work.
And that's the movie they meet up, learn about each other's fears.
Then a bear pops out. You might as well watch Buffy instead. They certainly do.
Are we going to get copyright claim for this?
So try to enjoy a film that feels like a long pilot episode for a show that CW
passed on that manages to be one quarter asked horror flag.
One quarter asked breakfast club,
one quarter asked why a romance and one quarter superhero movie.
And when you add all that up, you get something that's 100% complete.
I can't believe that I killed my grandma off to see this movie
story. Well. Well, well, if it isn't Slipknot,
the dad who can climb anything dream week. Yes.
Hello. This is dog.
I don't want your life in mother Russia wig.
Whereas you flame on flame off flame off gives good domes
nightmare at the Roxbury DOB air.
And I kiss the girl and I liked it that taste ever.
Harry dogleg, teenage mutant spacing hurdles.
Okay. Danny can see into people's fears, but none to the future.
So when she sees those clips from Logan and Dr. Rayez head,
she's scared of that scene happening or do they just screw up the X-Men timeout
again? Just for old time's sake. Oh, you guys, I'm not going to miss you at all.
This episode is sponsored by state farm, like a good neighbor state farm.
Is there roses are red storm. Clouds are gray.
There is no war in bossing.
Say I'm an auditor with a dark side
to him. I can't think of anything for him to say.